all right you're done let's talk about
how I solve this one let's take a look
at the sunshine service you just wrote
to begin with it's useful to have some
constants a log tag so we can actually
see how it's functioning and most
importantly this location query extra we
use this location query extra to pass
the location query into our intent
service in on handle in 10 we actually
put the code that we had in doing
background in our fetch weather task
however as you can see the only
parameter we get is an intent so we pull
the location query out of a string extra
using the location query extra string we
can copy the rest of the code from
fetchweathertask here because in temp
service also create the helper thread
for us to run code on similar to what
async task does note that we also fix up
all of the code that refers to M context
as a service also has its own context
the final thing we do is call our
service from update' whether within
forecastfragment
we simply put an extra for the location
query instead of using it as a parameter
and then start the service then we can
delete the fetchweathertask
and its associated tests